[Music]
you guys Taylor Swift just freaking
slayed her performance on Good Morning
America Taylor saying two singles off
her new album lover in front of a
massive crowd in New York's Central Park
bringing the house down with me
[Music]
and just watch her kill it singing you
need to calm down
[Music]
of course Taylor had to bring back fan
favorite and my personal life anthem her
2014 hit shake it off
[Music]
just look at that crowd you guys
Taylor's fans aren't messing around the
fans were here just camping out
overnight yeah you heard that right they
slept on the street
in New York City to watch Taylor that is
some serious loyalty and it didn't go
unnoticed by Taylor and her team your
dad was actually out handing out pizza
overnight yeah and it just as a family
like it blows our mind that that people
would want to do that like like you know
for my parents they're like that's my
kid people are waiting on the sidewalk
to see her saying like that's it's
really astonishing to us before Taylor
was shaking it off on stage she sat down
with Robin Roberts
to spill some serious tea including this
little tidbit about her upcoming MTV
Video Music Awards performance
I'm opening the show so that's exciting
I don't know if I was supposed to say
that but I've done it now so can't take
it back oopsie Taylor also talked about
her new album and why it holds a
particularly special place in her heart
I mean one thing about this album that's
really special to me is that it's the
first one that I will own you've
probably heard about Taylor's recent
message calling out Scooter Braun for
buying her masters when he joined Big
Machine Records claiming that she quote
pleaded for a chance to own her work but
was instead quote given an opportunity
to sign back up to Big Machine Records
and earn one album back at a time one
for every new one I turned in I think
that artists deserve to own their work I
just feel very passionately about that
she decided to leave big machine and
signed with Universal and well Taylor
pulled a badass boss move revealing
recently that she plans to rerecord her
old music that's true and it's something
that I'm very excited about doing
because my contract says that starting
November 22